[Musique]
depuis le début de la pandémie de
covid-19 des centaines de millions de
personnes ont attrapé le virus
qui que certaines d'entre elles ont été
gravement malade voire en soi décédés
alors que d'autres ont eu peu ou même
pas de symptômes la réponse pourrait se
trouver dans notre ADN
contre la covid-19 les grandes règles
sont bien connues
des facteurs comme l'âge l'obésité ou
les problèmes cardiaques sont des
handicaps ils augmentent le risque de
souffrir d'une maladie grave
mais il reste une part de hasard
des gens jeunes au sommet de leur forme
tombe gravement malade
d'autres au contraire ne sont pas
touchés malgré leur rencontre
répétitives avec le virus
comment l'expliquer la réponse est
peut-être écrite dans notre code
génétique
des petites variations dans l'agencement
des quatre éléments de base de notre ADN
pourrait modifier notre réponse au virus
une mauvaise pioche pour les uns une
combinaison gagnante pour d'autres
si Dominique domaine manie le poil long
avec tant d'enthousiasme c'est qu'il a
bien failli ne jamais remettre les pieds
dans sa cuisine
plus de goût
originaire des Philippines infirmiers de
formation il s'est recyclé dans la
restauration un peu avant la pandémie
très heureux c'est ma passion
à 37 ans son dernier problème de santé
remonte aux années 90 une pierre aux
reins mais en mai 2021 il attrape la
covid
[Musique]
j'ai dû aller à l'hôpital
de la fièvre une éruption cutanée des
maux de tête et je vomissais
un mois à l'hôpital dont plusieurs jours
intubés aux soins intensifs ces poumons
ses reins sont froid on lâchés
entre la vie et la mort
les médecins ont conclu qu'il avait
souffert d'un syndrome inflammatoire
multicystémique provoquée par le virus
une complication rare de la covid-19
si rare que des chercheurs ont inclus
Dominique domaine dans leurs études
[Musique]
à l'Institut de recherche les 10 des vis
de l'Hôpital général juif de Montréal
une équipe dirigée par l'endocrinologue
Brant Reacher tente d'élucider ce
mystère pourquoi certaines personnes
subissent des complications de la
maladie alors qu'ils n'ont aucune
prédisposition connue
pour croire quelqu'un a eu dans les
déchets verts un autre personne a eu
presque rien des symptômes même âge même
situation économique même facteur du
risque comme d'obésité comme le diabète
mais malgré ça il y a une grande
différence dans la sévérité de le covid
19 avec son collègue infectiologue
Guillaume bottleuin la porte ils
explorent une piste encore peu
fréquentée la génétique
en médecine ce qu'on se dit c'est il
doit y avoir quelque chose de plus puis
si on éliminé l'environnement les
facteurs épidémiologiques mais il reste
vraiment juste la génétique
notre ADN peut influencer notre réponse
aux maladies infectieuses on sait par
exemple que certains gènes ont un impact
sur notre réaction à une infection par
le virus de la grippe dans le cas du VIH
un gène protecteur a été identifié il y
a déjà plus de 25 ans mais le domaine
reste relativement méconnu on savait pas
trop en quoi qu'on s'embarquait même les
communautés scientifique est-ce qu'on
allait réellement trouver quelque chose
qu'elle allait nous permettre de trouver
des thérapies puis finalement on était
agréablement surpris c'est un effort
colossal mené par des centaines de
chercheurs partout sur la planète qui
puisent dans d'immenses banques de
données génétiques
pour en tirer des conclusions les
experts mènent des études dites
pangénomiques
ils comparent les génomes entiers de
centaines de milliers de personnes
cataloguées dans ces bio banques avec
ceux de milliers de patients
hospitalisés ou morts de la covid-19
pour trouver d'un film variations dans
l'ADN qui pourraient être responsable
avec cette information on voit que
peut-être une certaine pourcentage de la
population à une variation comme une
lettre C dans le ADN et l'autre partie
de la papillation de la traiter et la
question que nous posons c'est que si
les personnes qui ont laissé si ils ont
une tendance à la sévérité de covid 19
qui est plus élevé que les personnes qui
a la lettre T
de cette manière les chercheurs ont pu
identifier quelques dizaines de portions
du génome ou des variations génétiques
sont liées à la sévérité de la covid
c'est tout des petits effets additifs il
y a certaines régions qui augmentent
beaucoup le reste il y a d'autres
régions qui le montent un petit peu
moins puis
chaque personne est comme sur ce spectre
là puis du monde sont très malchanceux
évidemment mais ouais c'est entre 20 et
30 régions on distribué sur le génome
qui finalement
ont quand même un gros rôle à jouer sur
à quel point ce qu'on va être malade
une de ces régions se trouve sur la
troisième de nos 23 terres de
chromosomes quelque part dans ces
milliers de molécules ou de lettres qui
composent l'ADN des petites
modifications peuvent doubler le risque
de certaines complications de la
covid-19 ça c'est une de les plus grands
facteurs de risque
comme toutes les autres grands facteurs
de risque comme l'obésité comme le
diabète type 2 comme l'hypertension
alors ça c'est une facteur de risque à
peu près le même niveau que ces facteurs
de risque clinique qui sont vraiment
bien connues par la population
si la loterie génétique peut augmenter
le risque de maladies graves d'autres
semblent au contraire avoir tirer le bon
numéro
[Musique]
sans compter qu'en plus des patients
elle s'est occupée en janvier 2021 de
son conjoint malade
on habite dans un deux et demi pas de
portrait donc il y avait aucune façon
pour moi de m'isoler de lui j'ai jamais
contracté j'ai passé à peu près de 12
tests durant ce moment-là par la suite
j'ai eu plein d'expositions aussi à
l'hôpital j'ai eu plusieurs fois des
gens autour de moi et le dernier Noël
aussi en fait toute ma famille et toute
la famille de mon conjoint ont été
testés positifs et je l'ai toujours pas
eu
dans l'espoir de comprendre Raphaël
Dupuy s'est porté volontaire dans une
étude menée par l'équipe du docteur
donaldvin au Centre universitaire de
santé Miguel
tous les prochaines découvertes sur ce
tableau
c'est ça exactement
le microbiologistes infectiologues
s'intéressent à ceux qui ont eu
jusqu'ici l'avantage sur le virus il y a
des personnes qui sont qui semblent être
complément résistants c'est à dire ils
ont fait des tests soit PCR ou être
rapide PC était toujours négatif et ça
c'est intéressant parce que ça suggère
que ces personnes sont résistants par la
maladie mais même en amont de
l'infection et nous on cherche pour les
raisons génétiques ou moléculaires pour
expliquer cette résistance en espérant
que ça peut nous éventuellement donner
des outils à combattre la pandémie on
peut regarder l'impact sur la
morphologie en espérant qu'on voit
quelque chose vraiment
d'identifier des variations génétiques
protectrices en comparant le génome de
Jean apparemment résistant au virus avec
celui de personnes infectées
qu'est-ce que ça va nous donner c'est au
lieu de regarder 22
000 jeunes dans le dans les génomes
humaines ça va nous donner des pistes à
poursuivre peut-être quelques centaines
de jeunes et on va faire après ça des
tests moléculaires ou biologiques pour
prouver que en fait ces variantes et
mutations dans les gènes sont
responsables pour la résistance clinique
qu'on voit
donaldvin collabore avec des chercheurs
d'un peu partout dans le monde pour
recruter le plus grand nombre possible
de ces chanceux qui ont échappé à la
covid-19
on charge pour des gènes qui pourraient
être rares pour ce qu'on appelle une
résistance intéressée c'est-à-dire que
les deux copies de jeunes doivent être
doit porter les variant pour expliquer
la résistance et donc on cherche pour
vraiment une aiguille dans la
pour les chercheurs une fois trouvé les
bonnes aiguilles dans la botte de foin
génétique de nouvelles solutions
devraient émerger alors le but ici c'est
de pas juste
identifier des gènes ou des molécules
qui expliquent la résistance mais de le
trait de venir pour que ça devient des
nouveaux traitements
[Musique]
aussi la vie de l'équipe de brawlighters
pour ça il mise entre autres sur une
autre région du génome située sur le
chromosome 12
là un gène appelé OAS 1 contrôle un
mécanisme lié à l'élimination de la RN
virale par nos cellules
or des niveaux plus élevés de protéines
produites par ce gène réduisent le
risque de complications liée à la
covid-19 et les chercheurs ont pu
montrer que ceux qui portent un variant
de ce gène sont mieux protégés contre
les complications la preuve selon eux
que cette variation génétique entraîne
une protection
ce que ça veut dire finalement c'est
qu'on est non seulement capable de poser
la question est-ce que le variant est
associé à maladie ou est-ce que la
protéine est associée à la maladie mais
est-ce qu'elle cause la maladie c'est
cela la qui est génial avec la génétique
c'est que toutes ces associations là si
on les utilise correctement on peut
répondre une question causale et non
seulement une question d'association
récemment une étude clinique a justement
montré qu'un médicament qui influence la
quantité de Ice dans l'organisme peut
réduire le risque de complication de la
covid
ils ont remarqué
diminuation de la Mission Locale visite
la salle de gens et la salle de soins
intensifs par 50%. et je vais juste une
injection nous savons que cette
médicaments influence le gène que nous
avons trouvé alors c'est pas juste pour
stratifier le population avec les
génétiques mais c'est pour trouver les
cibles pour les médicaments pour traiter
toute la population qui ont eu une
infection avec le
de quoi réjouir Dominique domaines pour
qui participer à ses recherches à l'aide
soit après avoir frôlé la mort de près
[Musique]
mais pour moi c'est une deuxième vie et
il faut en profiter
comprendre
notre réponse aux infections pourraient
permettre de mieux les traiter
ça ouvre les portes à finalement trouver
une meilleure thérapie pour beaucoup de
maladies dont plusieurs ont été négligés
pendant longtemps il y a tout un champ
de recherche qui vient de s'ouvrir puis
on avait aucune dégustation
dans notre combat contre le virus les
gagnants comme les moins chanceux
peuvent nous aider à prendre notre
revanche
[Musique]